this is a movie that you wrote a little
bit a little bit ago yeah I think eight
years ago eight years ago yeah the core
story was always pretty much the same
the the very first draft took place in
the 80s so we did write it with 80s in
mind so there were references to some
jams it lost a lot of great jams a lot
of jams jokes but you know pretty
quickly we realized one our budget would
go up and also it just felt like better
that we create some kind of timeless
feel that we really wanted the the the
station wagon to speak about who Trent
was and the Owens car to speak to him
and the music to sort of be across a ray
you know so a big different an array of
time period and styles and stuff like
that and so in John Rose I think with
the help of the you know the momentum of
the descendents it was in this script
came back to us about three years ago
after had gone through sort of turn
around and we had ownership of it again
I think that's when we decided to helm
it ourselves and and really you know you
know live or die by what we put out
there and do it on our own terms and
hope that we could succeed and so we
really sort of took a you know a very
grassroots approach in terms of
attracting talent and wrote personal
letters and and attracting financing and
and that's sort of the way and it's very
gratifying and rewarding than to be at
this point and to you know at least put
the movie you know have the vision
complete from start to end I used to
watch these guys perform and loved them
as as actors comic actors and
improvisational actors and and this part
has always been a part the part of Betty
has always been a part I wanted to play
when I first read the the very first
scene which is kind of a knockout scene
for for any one day at to play until you
realize you have to do it over and over
again on the same day it was it was it
was truly one of the most exhausting
things I've ever done in my life that
character I even got a phone call I have
to tell you this I got a phone call from
my doctor my GP
who called me who saw me in the movie
nice said Allison I have to I don't know
I've never seen you like that before I
know you were channeling somebody
because you are that you have such low
blood pressure and you're so like he
could not believe that I was give that
much energy we were all so lucky were
working with an incredible level of
talent that we were you know it wasn't
difficult but I think in general
creative rust I think is things and and
have a enjoy what you're doing I think
you know in when we've had directors as
actors that where it's loose and
everybody's having a good time and
you're sort of your professional but
you're enjoying what you're doing as you
know I think that's that makes a huge
difference and and my favorite well I
have to tell is that my favorite bit of
direction they gave was um and they were
like one it was they've been together so
long that they they finish each other's
sentences they you know it's just like
having two of the same person on the set
does that make sense so okay um but but
with Peter Alexandra the young boy who
played my son I think Jim came over to
me and said just you're an old married
couple go just and and that just I was
so much fun to play that direction with
that young boy who was an extraordinary
extraordinary actor going inside and her
saying where's your eye patch I lost it
I mean that's just them riffing so by
that time they were married divorced
remarried by that time no so we had
casting sessions in LA and Liam James
who played Duncan flew down from
Vancouver and really as soon as he
walked in the door I think both Jim and
I sort of sat up in our chairs I think
because physically he did have all the
attributes that we were looking for just
the concave chest and shoulders that
were sort of slumped and he was sort of
you know much like Jim very pale and I
embrace it and and so it was like oh
please just be able to say the lines
close and he was great he was incredibly
grounded and very natural and honest and
you know we we definitely saw a lot of
kids that were were great but maybe a
little more rehearsed and polished than
we were looking for and and Liam just
felt you know he was 15 it just felt
like he was living this
was the age yes it was basically of one
of the my favorite summer vacations I've
had a working summer vacation filming a
movie about a summer vacation because it
was this town in south shore boston
called it was in Marshfield the town was
called me in harbin arms areas called
green green harbor green Harbor Green
Haven Green haba we wrote a long letter
to Steve Carell to play the role of
trend in and you know he very very
thoughtfully and kindly wrote a nice
letter to us back saying while he loved
the script very much you know lest he
become a trend to his own family he he
couldn't commit because that was a time
that he spends in Marshfield you know on
summer vacation with his kids and so
then we went back to him and said what
if we shot in your backyard
that seems thing it's all on this one
street that paralleled the the beach and
and and we rented Tony had a house on
that strip and then I did to my I shared
a house with the with the set decorator
and the production designer Mark Ricker
and an Rina D'Angelo we shared a house I
decided I would go outside my comfort
zone because I usually I go I travel I
do these movies and I stay in a hotel
room and I was I don't want to be lonely
this summer I really don't I decided to
live share a bathroom with three people
and that's that's scary when you're over
30